[Music]
hello and welcome to the beyond
us series by the institute of art and
ideas
my name is bernardo castro my name is
fred matzer
in this series of four episodes we will
explore
four concepts that underpin and define
the modern world
knowledge competition language and
growth
and in each we're joined by a different
leading thinker to help us and hopefully
you
to see each concept in a new light
in this the first episode of the series
we discuss
knowledge how we come to know things
what knowledge
is for and what the limits of knowledge
are or might be
and we are very happy to have one of the
world's most knowledgeable people on the
topic of knowledge here with us today
the canadian philosopher and champion of
the enlightenment project
rebecca goatstein welcome rebecca hello
fred and hello bernardo it's really a
pleasure
to be able to speak with you today it's
great to see you rebecca it's a
big topic we are going to cover today so
maybe to calibrate expectations for for
the listeners we don't plan
on covering the topic of knowledge
to any great extent it's an enormous
topic
but it's a topic of a lot of relevance
for us in society today
what can we know what do we know um
and maybe we can explore a little bit of
that
so that's exactly how i'd like to start
and maybe
start with you rebecca um
how do we know that the things we think
we know
are really true i mean what can we know
with certainty and
and how can we know things with some
degree of confidence in your view
yeah well we obviously think we know a
great deal
more than we do know and um
that is a very good thing to always keep
in mind it's perhaps one of the most
important things i mean it has great
ethical implications as well because
we act on our beliefs uh
so as far as now i you know
very little can be known with certainty
so we need to come up with
lesser standards of justification
of to distinguish between you know what
we
have good reason to believe you know we
can say we
know although we leave open doubt
uh we leave open the possibility of
counter evidence uh but um so you know
we have to
certainty is very very rare
um and where do i think what do i think
i know with certainty
um i know that i'm conscious there is no
way
for me to be wrong about that the very
grounds
for believing it true render it true
right
very few beliefs that we have
have such epistemic considerations
um i'm quite certain of
yes when there's a proof i'm quite
certain of it although
i've spent a lot of time i've written a
book on girdles
and completeness theorems and so even
there you know there is uh room for
doubt uh but that there is that i'm
conscious and therefore there is
consciousness
in the world um yeah i would say that's
a
really epistemically
special proposition everything else
we're going to have to
make to with lesser standards
i have a mental faculty to digest
information
and process information but i also have
a feeling faculty
i have a mental faculty that expresses
itself in words and numbers
so i can compare and i can communicate
communicate
internally but also with other people
through words
but i apart from the mental faculty i
also have a feeling faculty
and the more that feeling faculty is
less is is uh reef
is not having emotions the more
free i can feel if that what
comes on my feeling screen
is good information based my decisions
on
to what extent rebecca do you see our
ability to
intuitively feel things that felt
intuition that comes naturally and not
through the mediation of
concepts in symbolic thinking to what
extent do you consider that a
reliable source of knowledge can we rely
on that
and if we don't are we missing something
by disregarding our feeling faculty
look i'm just saying i mean i am a very
skeptical
person uh to me it's uh every knowledge
claim i'm um
i'm trying to think of how it could be
wrong
and uh um
i have feelings uh they are
um i think uh it's unavoidable
to depend on them i think that uh
the history of metaphysics for example
is the
study of temperament right you know you
go through
a nursing different temperaments and
different
intuitions and there's a great big gap
between what we can prove
uh you know mathematically logically
uh you know a priori proof
um the empirical evidence we have
and our view of the world what we need
in order to orient ourselves
in this reality you know that we
you know this makes us very special as
the you know these evolved apes that we
are
we really want to know where are we
what kind of reality is this how do we
fit in
with it are we of the same stuff or not
you know these basic metaphysical
questions
uh and what do we used to do with our
time here you know these are the basic
normative questions so you know we are
we are the philosophical animal
and we need you know proof can get us so
far experience can get us so far
we need this sort of intuit intuitive
temperamental feeling
which which is individually variable
you know the more you've been a
philosopher and
gotten into these conversations with
people with whom you radically disagree
about the nature of reality
the more you realize there are
temperamental differences there
some people for example are allergic to
mystery
i mean they have to reduce everything to
something
that they can you know understand and
solve it's got to be solvable
they can't some people revel in mystery
the more mystery the better
and some people accommodate themselves
to mystery you know they recognize those
limits of human understanding
and they wish there were fewer mysteries
but you know
this is such a temperamental difference
between us and it's it's feelings it's a
sort of general who knows you know what
it is it's psychology
um and so yes
i i think that's why i so agree with the
fred's uh remarks to me before we
started speaking about dialogue
because it's so important that you talk
to different people who have
different intuitions or filling up the
gap between
proof and empirical evidence and their
entire orientation of the world
um who who feel a very different way and
and then you recognizing yourself
oh yeah something's something subjective
here maybe it's right maybe it's not
but um you hold it with a little
less uh tenacity which would be good i
think
moving on to a very related but slightly
uh different topic um it doesn't take
much if we watch
the news today um to see that we are
living through a major
crisis of knowledge the whole idea of
fake news alternative facts things that
we thought we knew before
and we didn't even question them are
being called to question so there is a
new level of
skepticism but at the same time this
skepticism
comes paired with an unbelievable
openness to nonsense conspiracy theories
that are well defies one ability to
to have a serious conversation um
where is this stemming from have we
defined knowledge rebecca in your view
in such a restrictive way post
enlightenment
that it's leading to a backlash now in
which people are trying to
like unguided missiles open up uh what
knowledge
means what it means to know something
what it means to have
facts or alternative facts yeah
so um
this is an extremely large question and
i don't think that this is
uh anything so very new um
there is a uh
um i i spoke about you know when the
first question you know what can we know
with certainty
very little and that so we have to lower
our standards um
and we use these um
degrees of justification for example
it's a very
a very important notion in epistemology
is
inference to the best explanation you
know we
get all this evidence and we try to put
it together in some kind of coherent
story um and it's uh extremely important
it's extremely important in science we
don't have
proofs in science we have inference to
the best explanation
and that's why theories and why we have
revolutions
in in science you know new evidence
comes it overturns we have to
come up with another theory and it's all
probably true you know in the light of
the evidence but
uh inference to the best explanation
there's also a subjectivity there what
counts as the best explanation you know
so one of the things that we use
uh is you know a coherence we want
um a global and the more global the
better
explanation for what we are seeing that
is
uh so simplicity counts here
um i'm trying to say what i'm going at
here
is that some of what leads
to this as you put it nonsense dangerous
nonsense
extremely dangerous nonsense um i want
to talk about that in a moment
um because i feel this extreme very very
personally
um but um some of the what leads to it
are the
very epistemic criteria that we use
in our best thinking inside you know the
simplest explanation
a global explanation we also there are
certain ethical intuitions that come
and we want to think in terms of good
and evil we want to think in terms of a
walt disney movie right to come you know
they're the good guys and the bad guys
right
um i i it's funny because you know i
mentioned
good girl who who proved the
incompleteness theorems
and one of the things he said you know
in some ways he was a very
childlike man he said life should be
like a walt disney movie
you know we know who the wicked witch is
and we don't like her
so that yes even the most that's
all of this goes into um these
conspiracy theories you know i have a
global explanation for everything
also what feeds into them is the feeling
of
aggrievement life is not treating me
well
it's somebody's fault um the reason i
say that it's not
so very new and some you know it's new
to us
we just burst its scenes
onto the stage i would like to say that
every um member of my family of my
generation
including me and everybody who was born
post world war ii we are
all named after dead children why
because there was a conspiracy theory
and it had
global ramifications people
died right so my family was from hungary
uh jewish obviously you can tell by my
name
so this is you know this is this
and it was a story of a global
conspiracy why
how can we explain this here are these
people in control
this they want to rule the world they're
evil all we have to do is wipe them out
you know it's in their blood it's in
there you know wipe out the infants
right but
you don't this is this is it's not
something new
but it is hijacking certain knowledge
bearing you know the way we come up with
explanations
right and so it's it's a very hard
thing to um extirpate
and it's the most important question
that we face right now
how do we how do we fight this uh one of
the things is how do we address the
sense of agreement some of the theory
justified
that feeds into this kind of simplified
theory uh but uh yes i think
i could go on and on about this but but
that's that's my short answer
we know that from einstein also and
galileo
or others when they relaxed and they
were not
using their mind their mind was used
by what we don't know the big composers
boss modes are they all new when they go
into the zone
it allows them to get access to certain
levels of harmony that we recognize as
very pleasant
or some instinctual knowledge that is
not related to your
ego self your chattering conceptual mind
that is not a rational process it's
allowing something to happen
like when the great singers or even
yourself and
perhaps or rebecca you sing and of
course you can
you can do a song but i'm not a singer a
very bad it but sometimes i try to
improvise
and then there's no way that you can
think what you're going to sing
because you just follow where the
vibration brings you
and you can then with whatever opinion
look back or just was
amazing or stupid or whatever but you
went on a ride on an adventure
i couldn't agree more with the final
state that fred is describing it's one
of the most glorious expansive
self-transcendent experiences that one
can have
this sort of flow the coming out of
oneself
and feeling the boundaries of
yourself melting away um yeah this is
one of the greatest
experiences but one can actually achieve
it in so many different ways
you've mentioned art and yes you know
music and i don't only do
uh philosophy but i also write novels
and i know this
i know this magic of being taken out of
yourself
completely uh there is no time
you know when this is happening it isn't
you know and it's uh
when it's forever grateful to have this
not everybody does um but uh it is
something to be cultivated and it's
something
um and i think you you actually hit on
something children have
you watch a child at play they are lost
in it they're lost in their play and so
you know i
wish that we could get at that
in childhood instead of teaching it away
you know uh and rather cultivate it so
all of that is very important
but you know what reason can do it as
well i'm a
great fan of spinoza
he's really the person who you know
some people i know they their their
mantra is what would jesus do when
they're faced with a difficulty my
mantra is what would spinoza do
right he is my go-to guy so
um but you know for him it's really it's
rational reason it's argumentation that
gets you
uh out of yourself you know to a place
of and math can do it too i mean some of
my
most transcendent moments have been
mathematical so you know pure
reason can also do this to get
you know math gets you you are touching
infinity not just the infinity of
natural numbers
you are trusting infinities beyond
infinities beyond infinity
uncountable numbers of infinities that
we can do this
we evolved apes you know that we can
touch infinity
through reason this is again thank you
thank you whatever allows us to do this
so i just want to say
yes there's art there's music
no one and um
worship this this more than i do um i've
in fact uh
often compromised my philosophical
career by doing something so
unreasonable as writing a novel
you know i think that was a my
colleagues were not so happy about this
but
in any case you know so it's something i
really believe in
but i just want to say reason is a way
of doing this as well
pure reason um a priority reason so
that is also a fantastic gift that we
have
no no i think it's a very very good
i i i see the experience because when
rebecca
is talking about it she is reliving it i
see
it in action so i mean and that gives me
a good feeling
so yeah if yeah if i may um
by the way i share a lot of what you
what you
related um for instance very few things
in the world can make me
cry but if i if i'm not careful
and i'm looking at euler's equation and
i really think about what i'm seeing
there
it's one of the things that that can
bring me to tears because it
how is that possible how can that be
um so but we rely on mathematical
knowledge which is seemingly impersonal
because
although it's mental we all seem to
agree um
so there is an objectivity to that
mental space which is very hard to
wrap one's head around but would you say
you stress that
reason like mathematical reason is how
also
a form or a way of getting contact with
this
intuitive stream of knowledge so you
left the door open for
others would you say that intuitive
knowledge related to art
or to spiritual practice is as reliable
as this mathematical knowledge that
apparently flows from some platonic
realm beyond ourselves
yes um
you know the this inter-subjectivity
that we do have in mathematics that we
we all you know agree pretty much you
know when it comes to foundations of
mathematics
oh forget it because that's philosophy
right so then we are disagreeing all
over the place right
when it comes to mathematics itself yeah
um
there is that intersubjectivity and that
is interesting but
these other things you know um even
well spirituality uh it's a very
vague word it depends what one means by
it you know
if we're talking about this sort of
transcendence of the self that we can
get to
through all sorts of means if that's
what we mean by spirituality well
i i do think in some sense you know to
to experience it
is to believe in it you know it is it is
also it's a
and who can you know it's um but we do
come to very different views
uh when we're in this state so there
isn't that intersubjectivity
so you do feel okay something individual
is feeding
into this thing and so it doesn't seem
quite
as as reliable so i would uh
you know the kinds of things that i
think are true because of
when i my ego melted away and i seemed
to grasp
the arm um you know i'm
i'm less certain i would not it's not a
hill i'm ready to die on
euler's equation that's a hill i'm ready
i will die
on that bill yes uh even i would be
happy to lie on that one
how do you see this rebecca do you think
since the enlightenment
we have gone down a path of putting
reason on a
pedestal and sort of ignoring other
aspects of
our psychic faculties
other psychic functions that we have as
animals living on this planet
um no no the short answer is no i don't
um and uh but i i do respond
uh strongly to something that fred has
said
um i use my reason to try to
um to arrive at this point um
i
we are creatures uh you know driven by
evolution
as all things we are we let me go back
further let me go back to physics
the most basic we are like all things in
resistance to contributing right it
takes a tremendous amount of
energy and resistance entropy will get
us in the end the second law of
thermodynamics always wins
but we're put you have to in order to
live in order to evolve
in order to make progress in order to
have knowledge in order to do anything
you have to be resisting entropy
right and uh okay so
so we matter to ourselves we come into
every creature matters to itself that's
how
you know basically how we resist entropy
we matter we pay
attention to what is going to what in
our environment is going to promote
our welfare and what's going to hurt us
and we react
we humans um have
this very big brain that gives gave
gives our mothers much trouble and
delivering us into this world
right because we have this we are fully
loaded
the frontal cortex is only loaded we are
able
we have self-consciousness as well as
consciousness we look at ourselves
and we are able to ask this question to
yeah i act as if i matter do i really
matter what is it about me
that makes me matter so much and it's
very humbling
and it makes us very ambitious and we
try to prove
one way or the other that we're worth
all the attention that we have to give
ourselves just in order to bloody live
right as all creatures must right but no
we have to come up we have to justify
our existence we are not just homo
sapiens we are homo
justifications right we are out to
justify
our existence we can do it through money
we can do it through competitive you
know competition i matter more
we can do it through our this
transcendence right i mean i
i you know to to experience
what we experience when we transcend you
know is to feel
i matter i'm in touch with the universe
along with the universe which
surely matters right we can do it you
know
because we feel that god loves us we can
do it many
different ways we can do it in our
relationships with one another
uh and so but that
we are the creatures who are trying
somehow to justify
our existence is both a testament to
ourselves
you know we accomplish great things you
know
mozart trying to produce that music
as a way of mattering einstein trying to
understand
the laws of nature as a way of mannering
but we also do
atrocious things you know only a
creature that longs
to prove what every other creature just
does
struggle for existence but we try to
prove that we're actually worth it
could have achieved what we've achieved
both
in terms of the wonders and the utter
atrocities
and so yes i again i say yeah let's hand
it to you
give it to us that's it we're we are
something
quite special that we try to do this but
it also makes us
fall into
atrocities terrible things right i come
back
again to this so i think that we have to
understand
our species in this way and try to find
you know the competitive uh the
competitive mannering it never it never
goes well
and it never feels good because unless
you're you know somebody who everybody
calls dear
leader and won't dare to
show that they're superior to you um you
know like kim jong-un or something right
to otherwise it steps to you
unless you're a dear leader you're gonna
find somebody who's better than you so i
mean if this is what you need is to
this competitive mattering it's not a
good way
it's not it's not going it's very
insecure at best and it leads to
so much as fred has said leads to
terrible things for our species
and for the rest of the species for the
planet as a whole for future generations
not only of our species but of all
species
so we gotta we gotta work on these
things
and like rebecca said well we can be
idealist but we have the atrocities as
well
and that will be part of history and
part of it has been part of history and
it will be part of the future it is a
way apparently
you learn and i i on a different level
rebecca mentioned that resistance yes
time space exists by
the phenomena of resistance by polarity
so indeed life on this
planet of life in the universe is
perhaps not possible
without the phenomena of resistance
rebecca a point that is dear to me i
wanted to share it with you because you
study
these things and get your comments on it
um
it strikes me ever more often
how dangerous it is to have a little
knowledge
as opposed to actual knowledge a little
knowledge is more dangerous than
ignorance
the farmers plowing the fields are not
talking about the higgs boson or the
quantum fields
but we watching the news at 8 o'clock
and reading
scientific magazines we also talk about
the higgs boson and the quantum fields
as
concrete realities that have been proven
and that's it that's how things are but
when you actually know more than what
you hear on the 8 o'clock news or in
popular science magazine you know that
the higgs boson
and the quantum fields are theoretical
tools they are
convenient fictions they are metaphors
in terms of which we can explain how
nature behaves
but not only has nobody ever saw a higgs
boson nobody
has ever measured a higgs boson directly
because it decays before you can measure
it
so these are metaphors but these
metaphors
are now being taken by a
distinguished segment of society as
um ultimate truths and they are using
that to to beat
to beat on the other segments of society
how do you see that
there are lots of people who are proud
that look we found the higgs boson
therefore
this and this and this is right but they
do not quite know what the higgs boson
that we talk about
actually is it's a theoretical metaphor
that explains the patterns of
clicking of our instruments it's not
something that you can hold in your hand
um look i tell you i mean a lot of
scientists
themselves are philosophical i mean the
point that you're making isn't
philosophy
of of science it's philosophy of phys x
and um
you know it's the that is what is it
that we're really
doing and what do we really know when
we're doing physics
you know what what have we really
discovered about the world
not just an example what i meant is that
we're taking a theoretical metaphors and
abstractions
for solid facts and i see danger in that
i think i think that that's very true
and i think
you know it takes place not just i think
in science but i think that a lot of um
really the deepest religious thinking
is it's metaphoric right it's it's
really
uh exactly
and then people take it literally
you know exactly and
so this seems to be a great
yet another epistemic fallacy you know
metaphors can get us very far
right they as you say
physics is mostly meta they're models
and metaphors
right it's not the literal truth right
and um
but it's um uh
so we can extend you know our
epistemic reach um but it's very
misunderstood that we forget that it's
merely
metaphor and it it happens all over the
place you know
i think in some sense in science it's
not quite as dangerous it's sort of
annoying
to if you know if you've studied science
your whole life it's a little bit
annoying
there are spheres of life i think in
religion uh for example
um uh where it can be quite dangerous
you know because then you know
it's this is the ultimate truth this is
the way it is this is the way the world
is everything else is heresy
you know you know what falls from that
so
it's yet another one of these little
it's a good thing right the metaphor
this is amazing right that we're able to
form metaphors i have a daughter who's a
poet i mean her metaphors are
fantastic right but um
but uh you know to be human is to
enjoy so many gifts that always have
their dark side as well
everything you know it has also
accept i think love really
i don't know the dark side of love i
think
there isn't a dark side of love right uh
so uh
they always look for the dark side for
everything but i i've spent my life
looking for the dark side of love and i
can
so far that's fine i don't see any no i
don't find it
oh we have to wrap up so fred this has
been fantastic
rebecca equally um let's leave it
on that note uh we started with
knowledge and we ended with uh
love as the one epistemically reliable
thing
uh i think it's a great uh note uh to
wrap it with
thank you both it's been fantastic very
enjoyable
hopefully we will have a chance to to do
it again at some time
wonderful rebecca to meet you oh and i
hope next time
it will be in person and thank you
listener we hope you enjoyed this
conversation
we will be back in a few weeks with
episode 2 on competition
and i bet you can't guess who our next
guest will be
i hope you really have enjoyed the
conversation
and that it has helped to stretch your
mind
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today
to the institute of art and ideas at iai
tv